[Musique]
président a indiqué que l'attentât qui a
eu lieu vendredi rappelle que la menace
terroriste est toujours persistante dans
notre pays je suis en colère
par contre les français mais parce que
je sais depuis cinq ans que cette guerre
contre le terrorisme contre le
djihadisme contre l'islamisme contre
l'islam politique sera une guerre longue
difficile et éprouvant fed ont été
réelles du terroriste au corps de
l'enquète hassan ali s'est présenté
comme un pakistanais de 18 ans arrivé en
france en tant que mineur isolé mais en
analysant son portable les policiers ont
découvert une photo d'une pièce
d'identité selon ce document il
s'appellerait en réalité there has had
mehmood et aurait 25 ans fils et là les
huiles et là quel sens
l'idée de chercher des excuses ont fait
dévié de l'objectif y est implanté le
centre
encore une fois il ya une procédure de
reconnaissance de ce statut qui est très
précise je le redis qui fait intervenir
la préfecture les conseils
départementaux parfois un magistrat
quand on demande effectivement la
réalisation de tests osseux donc bah je
crois qu'il faut revoir cette loi alors
c'est une convention européenne sur les
mineurs isolés et il faut organiser avec
les pays d'origine
le retour de ces mineurs l'organisation
mondiale de la santé vient de
communiquer le cap des un million de
morts vient d'être franchi et c'est la
moitié de ces décès ont été enregistrés
dans quatre pays seulement les quatre
pays les plus touchés usa brésil inde et
mexique je pense toujours que la peur
est pire que le mal
et c'est ce qui se passe il ya trop
d'affolement trop grave a [ __ ] trop de
panique et je veux le dire à tous les
restaurateurs à tous les hôteliers à
tous les patrons de café à tous les
directeurs d'établissement sportif et
décision aujourd'hui ne sont pas prises
en fonction d'une réalité qui serait
celle de la circulation du virus qu'on
ne sait pas comment le virus se transmet
à tous ceux qui travaillent dans le
domaine des traites
la restauration nous serons à vos côtés
le poids de la mortalité à côté du poids
social être négligeable le point social
va être considérable parce que la peur
n'a pas été géré je crains et faillite
je crains des bars des restaurants qui
ferment je crains le désespoir et donc
pour ces entrepreneurs et ses
entreprises et leurs salariés
on fait tout pour éviter un confinement
général donc c'est inenvisageable que
j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit qu'on fait tout
pour l'éviter
et c'est le sens notamment des mesures
complémentaires qui ont été annoncées la
semaine dernière par olivier véran pour
limiter la proposition pour l'éviter
donc on peut l'exclure
enfin vous savez je pense qu'avec ce
virus on n'exclut rien ça sera pas un
regroupement général ce sera d un repos
finement localisés dans des endroits où
la situation notamment la mise en
tension des réanimations nous y
obligerait mais ça peut aussi aider des
mesures un peu différente at-il de
couvre-feu par exemple qui pourrait
s'appliquer à 23h par exemple en guyane
ils ont mis en place un couvre-feu à 19
heures qui a très bien marché je
préférerais que demain la police
nationale soit là où elle doit être là
où il ya des ré où on a des problèmes
avec des rodéos sauvages qui sont pas
malheureusement maîtriser aujourd'hui
sur la ville les problèmes de
cambriolages les problèmes de
stupéfiants
plutôt que d'aller verbaliser des
commerçants qui essaient de gagner leur
vie et faire remarcher l'économie
française évidemment il ya des sanctions
et orageux sanctions évidemment il ya
des sanctions dire que les patrons de
bars et restaurants qui refuseront de
fermer ce soir seront sanctionnés vous
savez on ne prend pas ces règles de
gaieté de coeur
donald trump n'a payé aucun impôt durant
dix des quinze dernières années
dernières années alors au total il n'a
payé que 750 dollars d'impôts fédéraux
en 2016 honnête on élection à la maison
blanche et autant en 2017
allez messieurs dames on ferme s'il vous
plaît
elle est rentrée chez moi
[Musique]